good evening members
good evening and welcome to this meeting
on the development committee i will now
read out the emergency evacuation
announcement jack can you hear okay
thank you sorry council almost can you
hear okay
should you be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entry doors to the hall
continue straight on go through the two
sets of double doors on the right hand
side to the car park which is the
assembly point
please do not delay your activate an ex
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by the
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silence
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during
the meeting when i invite you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop and for the audio recording
where possible please help by passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if
if you do touch the microphones next
page
members voting will be done by a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against the recommendations and then for
those wishing to abstain from voting
have we got apologies for absence i have
um councillor simon smith councillor
phil shaw and councillor lj newport
is there any others oh i'm sorry unless
you butcher she can't make it for family
issues
is there anyone else no substitute
members i've got
councillor mrs gudson substituting for
councillor shaw councillor gooding
substituting for councillor smith
and council mrs mason substituting for
councillor new mrs newport is that
correct
anymore no
number members attending councillor
simon woodson
minutes of the meeting held on the 24th
of june are these agreed members
thank you to receive any
item five to receive declarations of
interest
yes councillors
thank you non-pecuniary interest as i
uh do know a number of people who attend
the rainy baptist church
under item 7. thank you very much thank
you councillor stanley
uh not peculiar interest as a member of
the
rtc and i know the applicant
the first for which item counselor
stanley
cat uh councillor dry yeah i'm going to
do this in a minute
um if i stop everyone members item six
of the agenda relating to 140 eastwood
road raleigh is an application made by a
member of rocha district council
it would therefore be appropriate for
all members of the committee to declare
a non-procurement interest in that item
by virtue of being
acquainted with the applicant so that's
done and then we'll have any other um
decorations please members uh because
right thank you
anyone else yep
everyone's going to be covered for that
thank you counsellor
item six members
it's one for
eastwood road rally proposed first floor
extension and
i believe uh mike shanks you'll be doing
you're the officer that's right chairman
yeah thank you
thank you chairman um this application
as
members saw earlier wouldn't usually
come before this committee
it's called as a householder extension
normally delegated to officers but
in the interests of transparency this
application is made by a member of the
council and is therefore brought before
you tonight
you'll see it's the domestic residence
on the
south side of eastwood road shown with
the site outlined as you see here
it's to one of a pair 15 pairs of like
similar properties and it's not far
just west of the junction with white
house chase to here
if we could jump to the existing
elevations thank you
the design features a sort of chalet
style front
with a big prominent gable and what
we're going to be looking at is a
proposed
fairly modest first floor front dorma
type extension in here
on the on the front front roof slope if
we could switch to the photos please
our application site is this grey
building here and whilst we're on these
images i've asked members to look at the
precedents that are to this group
there's one to the attached neighbor
not quite the same design but the same
idea
and another one to the one opposite and
if we go through the photographs please
we should see
here it is in better detail this is our
application site this is a better shot
of the one that will
face it that already exists here and
again please the next one
that's our application site like the
plan we just saw we're talking about
this area of roof slope in this part
and again please this is the other
attached
in better detail in the next one please
these are further along in the street
and you'll see there's a different
approach here a slightly slimmer dormer
and there's another one opposite which i
think is in the next photo down if i'm
right
there you go that that's that one there
the one we was just focused on here
basically chairman you'll see that
various other householders in this group
have had the same kind of idea but done
it in slightly
non-identical ways um if we can jump
to uh the proposed elevations please
here we see
what's before you tonight this is the
side view and this is the view as you
would see directed to the street here we
see the roof slope that we were looking
at earlier
and you'll see that there's a pitched
roof to a dormer type design to provide
an ensuite bathroom to the room behind
sideways on you'll see this little
window detail here which
serves the bathroom and then tucked
behind it is a slight front extension
but
hidden from view by the roofing proposed
and the front doorman
officers uh spoke with the applicants
about some slight amendments which you
see before you now this is the amended
scheme
and it was to just provide a slight roof
verge there
and to the sides to accord with your
policy on dormers
and also to make this window larger as
originally proposed it was like one of
these high-level letterbox windows
and we felt that the proportion of wool
massing to window
would make it look a rather blunt
feature
so we asked the applicants and they
agreed if they could make the window
larger and you'll see in the
recommendation
that of course because it's larger we
have to recommend that you um
obscure glaze it but it looks better
architecturally
and has a good design and form overall
so the recommendation chairman is
approval
subject to the conditions that are set
out in the report
thank you
members have anyone got any comments on
this please
counselor stanley now can we wait for
the mic please
because it's being recorded we might be
able to hear you
thank you um just one point um
is the window a fire escape
window as i
already know inside those properties
next door i actually know inside so
it's just something which was
brought to the attention of next door
neighbor when they put theirs up
thank you chairman um the short answer
is i don't know because it's not a
planning requirement it'd be under the
building rigs
um definitely the previous letterbox
type window wouldn't have been
and my limited understanding of the
building rigs that is this the room has
a certain escape within a certain
distance of that window then it's not
necessary but don't
quote me on that i'm not a building
inspector i think
we saw from the images before of the way
other
neighbours have done theirs they
featured windows of a similar size
so i would imagine providing the
building rigs are consistent and haven't
been changed then
it may be a requirement now that that is
an escape or it may be that this window
doesn't have to be an escape
but that's not an issue before this
committee or for
us as planning officers that's dealt
with and building rigs if as you say it
did need to be a fire escape window and
necessitated a design
then they can approach for something
they call a non-material amendment which
is a slight adjustment if the window is
increased
in by you know only those that would be
familiar with it would recognize but if
it
required a substantial revision then
they would possibly have to make a new
application and then that would come
back before you but a minor tweak of the
window
that can be done under legislation for
what we call a non-material amendment
thank you council mrs mason
uh thank you madam chairman i i think
that this application stands on its own
merit and i'd like to move
for approval have you got a second
council medicine
councillor mrs gudson sorry thank you
our all in we've now had it moved are we
all in can i have a
show of hands please for in favor of
this application
please keep them up until sonia's
actually counted
that vote is unanimous and it's agreed
thank you very much
okay i'm just gonna have a couple of
minutes
because we've got to swap over the mics
for another officer
are you done yeah
yep thank you members
application item number seven is for the
radio baptist
uh church high street rally and claire
will be
the officer actually presenting this i
believe
thank you chairman this application is
for a two-story flat roofed side
extension
to an existing church hall as you can
see from the location plan
the site is within raley town centre
there are commercial premises to north
the to the north and also to the west
here and we have residential auto local
located to the south and to the eastern
area let's move on to plan two
this is a bit more of a closer up of the
site so the side is at a rally baptist
church
which consists of a main church building
to the south so here
and then a church hall located in this
position here and which was the former
school building
to the north the church is grade 2
listed and the church always considered
to be cartilage listed
i'm just moving to plan three
both buildings have been extended over
the years as can be seen from this
historical development plan with the
majority of works taking place in the
latter half of the 20th century
the original main hall is colored pink
so that's this building here
and located and the original church was
colored blue
just here it's to the rear of the church
hall where the works of proposed is
current applications so
in this area here is where we're looking
at the works
so i appreciate this is a bit small but
this is the existing um location
layout plan that we've got here floor
plan so it shows the existing
arrangement here we have a ground floor
kitchen toilet facilities in this area
ground floor
and first of all there's an activity
room kitchen and storage facilities
there is also an external staircase
located here
so if i show the pose now i'll zoom in a
bit more
so the proposal is to remove the
external staircase and create a
two-story flat roofed extension
at ground floor level this will provide
a foyer with access to a lift
along with other internal
reconfiguration work first floor
which is going along to the first floor
so that's here
there will be a mezzanine installed
within the original
original part of the former school
building so that's the mezzanine here as
you can see it's sort of inserted into
the original part of the school building
the two-story element will connect into
an existing ground floor building to the
eastern boundary so here
the works would enable more rooms for
different uses to enable the church to
expand on the services it offers to
residents
let me show you so this as you can see
is the site at the moment
and so we have the this is the existing
two-story extension you can see the
external staircase coming down here
and if i just show you a photo visual of
how the extension would appear
so that's this image here so that's that
particular angle so we're looking north
um within the site itself and as you can
see this is the two-story extension here
you can see the name of the base
sorry i'll just hold off for a minute
because i think i'm
is that better and as you can see so
we've got the two-story extension here
it was a name the base here and this is
the foyer and the lift shaft is in
located in this area here
so the key material planning
considerations are impact on built
heritage
impact on character impact on
residential amenity highway safety and
ecology
so this following photo just shows what
the site appears like from the streets
in a present
so you can see the old church hall here
and this is an
extended part of the main church
building which is
continues on to this area here and to
the where you can see the existing
two-story extension just about located
there
and then again this is another photo
visual but looking from the streets in
perspective
so as you can see this is where the
extension will be located
attach the existing two-story extension
which is here
and to the last part of the church hall
the county historic buildings advisor
does not support the application
concern has been raised regarding the
height of the extension above the
existing building
and that the extension would fail to
preserve the architectural interest of
the currently listed building
revised plans were provided during the
course of the application reducing the
height of the lift element of the
proposal to bring it in line with the
height of the rest of the extension
however this change was not considered
to address the concerns raised by the
historic building's advisor
and they retain their objection the
proposal is considered to exacerbate the
impact of the existing poor modern
additions to the rear
and would improve the existing break in
built form as viewed from the street
scene
the first officer reason for refusal
therefore relates to the harm the
proposal was considered to have
upon this kurdish listed building it
should be noted that within the addendum
the proposal has been confirmed as
acceptable by the baptists together
this is a separate process to a planning
application which has different
considerations
to assess with regards to impact and
should not be given significant weight
when considering this application
impact on character is another matter to
consider so given the positioning
thank you okay
given the positioning and sighting of
the two-story extension it would be
visible from the street scene
although the building encompasses an
existing two-story flat roof extension
the proposed edition would have a
greater prominence upon the street scene
and would be considered a former poor
architectural addition the use of flat
roofs at first floor create a large and
bulky addition which are unattractive
the glazed arcade would draw attention
to the extension from the public realm
adding to its prominence and
exacerbating its incongruous appearance
the proposal was considered to represent
poor design and will be considered
contrary to policy dm1
of the development management plan and
the mppf detrimental impact upon visual
amenity represents the second officer
reason for refusal here
looking at impact on residential amenity
the proposed development would position
be positioned away from neighboring
properties
and would not be considered to have an
overlooking overbearing or overshadowing
impact
any sound levels that would be generated
would be considered suitable for a town
centre location
and will not be considered any greater
than that which currently occurs on site
at present looking at highway safety
no changes are proposed to existing
vehicular access or parking
county highways do not object to the
proposal and there is not considered to
be a
detrimental impact upon highway safety
and finally looking at ecology
as the works are considered to a
gable-ended pre-1914 building to form
the mezzanine floor
there is a potential for bats to be
present if permission were to be granted
a condition requiring a bat survey to be
undertaken
prior to any works commencing should be
attached to an approval
chairman this application is recommended
for refusal for the reasons referred to
above
and outlined in the office officer
report
thank you very much we now have mr kevin
brown
from the rainy baptist uh we'll speak uh
mr brown you have five minutes and we
will give you
one minute notice
thank you
okay okay good evening ladies and
gentlemen of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak in support of
our planning application for raleigh
baptist church
i'd like to just highlight some points
regarding our plans
in advance of the planning report being
released we were made aware of the
objection being raised by
mr munsten from essex county council
team and our architect contacted both mr
mustang
and katie fowler to discuss a potential
way forward
to ensure the officers could support our
application
several emails were sent back and forth
to resolve the issues
our architect then contacted and spoke
to mr mustin
and he stated that the concern related
to the overall height of the building
the lift overrun and not the extension
itself
revised drawings were submitted reducing
the height of the roof
and removing the lift overrun and it was
thought that this had resolved the
problem
it was only when the report became
public that we were made aware that mr
mustin
uh continued to object to the scheme and
also raised objection to the extension
on the site with regards to the listed
building consent point of view rayleigh
baptist church comes under
the jurisdiction of the baptist union of
great britain and as such
we are one of the denominations whose
heritage enlisted building assets
are managed under the ecclesiastical
exemption scheme
within the baptist union that scheme is
operated by the lbac
the listed building advisory committee
they give advice
guidance and listed building consent
when it comes to the heritage buildings
and churches owned by the baptist union
that was the case with our application
and the church applied
for listed building consent from the
lbac
on the 7th of june this committee met to
discuss
the application from a heritage and
listed building point of view
the committee considered the concerns
raised by essex county council
regarding the height of the lift overrun
the roof and the extension to the base
they concluded that the amendment
submitted by the architect
improved the scheme and addressed the
issues that had been raised
the committee approved the application
subject to agree in some matters of
detail
and specification this approval was
communicated to mr muston
and rochford district council our
proposed scheme
extends the 1960 edition at the rear of
the base
by just two meters and from
becoming a blemish on the street scene
view far from becoming a blemish on the
street scene
viewed looking down the side of the
building we believe it enhances it
by replacing the unsightly metal escape
fire escape with a feature window that
replicates windows in the building
this addition is not visible from the
existing roof line and the current
building from the seat stream
perspective
and is only visible while looking down
the walkway between the two buildings
and it is approximately 23 meters from
the street footpath
the main purpose of this extension is to
enable us the flexibility of space
for the internal remodeling and for us
to become fully compliant
from the perspective of dda and the
equalities act 2010
it will join the two buildings on the
site enabling level
internal walking and wheelchair access
from the base building
right through to the front entrance
doors of the church and this allows full
access
to the first floor activity meeting room
via the lift
and gives us the space we require to
have a fully
compliant disability toilet and wet room
in the past the base has been used for
family events
parent and toddler groups line dancing
keep fit
children and youth groups community cafe
carers cafe
to name but a few things various other
charitably groups and organizations
have also hired the premises if our
proposal is approved
it will improve the function of the
church in serving the people of raleigh
by providing a more flexible space which
is accessible to all
enable us to provide support and
activities which promote mental health
and well-being and expanding our work in
partnership
with community groups and organizations
although we will be providing more
activities it will not lead to any
increase in vehicles on the site
as parking for the church is via the
public car parks
we believe that this redeveloped base
will have a positive effect
with its enhanced facilities and so be
an additional
asset for the people and the community
of rayleigh
i'd like to thank the committee for my
time this evening thank you mr brown
the visit uh the one visiting member
which i can't see
mr wootton would you have you got
anything to say do you like to speak on
this
thank you council
being um have you anything to say on
this
yes of course you can you have but all
members please note you have five
minutes
thank you chairman um having had been on
the site visit i'm familiar with the
church of course
um and having been to the site visit and
reading both the addendum and
the minutes and listening to the
presentation
both presentations um
i mean it's very interesting i
personally feel
that uh in line with what mr brown has
said
that this would be an asset to rayleigh
now we talk about this
the looking of its premises and even
just looking at that picture
if if they think that that's worse than
looking at rusty
ladders going up the side of a building
it amazes me
but i have one question if i may they
talk about the listed building now the
the old school part of the church the
red brick pile
and then it changes into the extinction
at the back is it all listed
or just that front part i'll ask the
officers to come back to you if you'd
like to carry on
right yeah good because the officer
okay now the extension on the side i'm
aware that the lift shaft was dropped
lower to be level
and it doesn't faze forward like normal
door dormers
so it's in keeping for me to think that
it's an extension of
six feet that does so much good with the
especially with the dda's assistance and
everything else
and i have to say listening to all
parties having done
the site visit and familiar and
listening to the good it could do
i personally have to say at this moment
in time i'd
i feel that this we should go forward
with this um
plan thank you uh claire could you
answer the question please
in answer to your question that the
whole of that uh church always listed
including the section to the rear okay
i've got councillor ease then councillor
williams
for clarity um as i am not the ward
member and i call this in
i'd like to explain how that happened
when the church
contacted me uh to ask
about the the process um i
then contacted councillor mike wilkinson
who was going to be taking it forward
he got too busy to actually take it on
on the tuesday night i contacted him and
he hadn't looked at it so that left me
no alternative
than to uh call
in myself i have explained that toward
counsellors
so as i uh was trying to be
clear to everyone on process um there
are a number of things that when
i wasn't familiar with this application
before it came to the council so
i came to this with fresh eyes
there are a number of things that
made me rather questioning what was
actually put in the report
the as council lawman has already said
i think the conclusion that the
street scene is not improved
is questionable uh at least
i i actually agree with councillor
lawrence i do think that it actually
will improve it um the dda facilities
that will come in as a result of this
are an improvement there are lots of
community facilities that are going to
be improved
and rayleigh ray baptist church is known
to be a very community orientated
church so it will very definitely be an
asset to the area
in 2015 members may not be aware but
there was a
full front
application made for the whole of the
front
look of the church to be to be remodeled
and that was passed now where i find
that odd
is that no mention was made of street
scene in that but we have a very small
proportion of the street scene which is
being used as the reason
for officer refusal for this which
doesn't seem to add up to previous
um conclusions
the last thing i would say is the
addendum that we've had today
asking for a bat survey does kind of
lend weight to the feeling that the
council's conservation officer has not
actually visited the site
because the although that yes there is a
roof in there
bats will not nest in
a uh in a roof that is actually
uh left open it is an open vaulted roof
in a hall that is regularly used so
it does kind of make me wonder whether
the heritage officer has actually
visited this site even
um so in conclusion i am minded to
recommend that the the community move
forward with this plan and
accept it thank you chair thank you very
much
um can i just come back on the ecology
point is that all right yes of course
just just to um clarify um that's not
something that's been
addressed by the conservation officer
that was something internally if
a building is of a certain style or
style and um
takes necessary boxes from the ecology
point of view to need a bat survey
that's something that we
request it's not something that's um the
conservation officer becomes involved
with at all
just wanted to sort of clear up that's
come from us internally
does that answer your question
counselors
thank you councillor williams thank you
chairman i was just wondering if we
could see
the photograph of as is now is that
available
thank you could we just go back to the
the proposed please thank you very much
as answered your question councilman
thank you thank you councillor foster
thank you now can you please wait for
the mic
and we can project
right thank you chairman unfortunately i
was unable to attend the site visit at
the weekend but
went there last night to check it over
i completely agree with the details of
referral as expressed by council at
hughes in paragraph 1.2
in the various paragraphs including
paragraphs 11 15 16 and 21
the report talks with visibility from
the street scene
and suggest that the development
detracts from the public realm
and is detrimental to visual immunity of
the street scene
i would contend that all these comments
are significantly exaggerated in fact
that picture is a good example because
on the as it is picture there's a bigger
bush blocking that view
the reality is this extension is so far
back
that that would not be visible from the
street scene by anybody driving or
walking
until they were level with that entrance
and they'd have to be level with it and
looking at right angles but
particularly to look at it just to know
the picture of the
way it will be i think that facial
design looks very good
i note also that there's been no comment
from rayleigh town council
and the content of the comments in the
response from the single neighbor that
responded
are in effect contradicted by impact on
residential amenities report in the
paragraph
19 and the highway safety comment in
paragraph
20. i would vote against refusal
and would support councillor eve's
proposal to accept
thank you chairman thank you very much
councillor fd
did you sorry did you want wait i
thought you're sorry councillor
did you actually indicate if not it'll
be counselor stanley
thank you
uh thank you chairman um first of all
could i ask the officer
is the height of the the
the uh planning application roof
the same as what it was before yes
it is ah because it didn't i can't
didn't see it
on the plan there it looked it looked
like it was higher because it was
at the top of the ridge that's there is
no if it is it's only
maybe a tiny tiny under your tongue yes
that's but that's fair enough um yes um
the the windows are going to be the same
from
what i understand from the speaker the
same as what they've got
on the front in design wise yes they're
certainly going to try and keep the
design in accordance with
the existing building as much as they
can and we can control that kind of
thing by
conditions i i rather like the design
myself because that's uh
it seems to be in keeping with the front
of the property although i'd like to see
uh perhaps uh a more
if you like the the ridge
indicated on the wall above the window
that would look really nice don't know
cancer
standing with that we're not discussing
that that's not planning there's no
that's not planning we're not planning
that but um yes i think
i think it's well accommodated in its
surroundings yes
so you've had your question answered yes
yes is that anyone else would like to
explain this
sorry uh yes sorry i didn't see your
counselor mrs mason and then
councillor
yeah um thank you chair um
firstly i'm glad that council i think it
was councillor williams
asked for the before and after photos to
be shown because i think they
demonstrate
a fast difference and i think i'd like
those shown again
so that we can clearly see
take away the tree but what we have
there is an ugly white
flat roofed building and that is quite
visible
there it would appear to be a
continuation of the historic building
albeit that it's not
however having read the report and i've
come fresh to this i hadn't uh
haven't been around to look at the site
so
i've only really seen and heard what's
going on tonight
the main objective seems to be the
dominance and prominence
of the proposal however
essex county council in their reports is
in their opinion
well in my opinion i don't think it is
overly dominant and i don't think it's
overly prominent
and i think it's an improvement
the excuse me counselor mason could you
speak into the mic because we've got
someone who's on a hearing loop who
can't actually hear you
okay thank you i'm usually quite loud
okay
can you hear me now yes we can thank you
can you hear now thank you
yeah okay we need to ask ourselves if we
look here
will the proposed development lead to
substantial harm
or of a designated heritage asset
and we should refuse consent if that was
the case
it says here unless it can be
demonstrated that the substantial harm
or total loss
is necessary to achieve substantial
public benefit that outweigh that harm
and loss
well firstly i don't think there is
substantial harm
i don't think there is any harm at all
on this i think it's an improvement
and certainly any harm any perceived
harm
is outweighed fastly by the public
benefit
and i have heard all the comments of the
proceeding counsellors and i think that
the
feeling i get from this floor is that
it's unanimous
or certainly there's a general appetite
to approve this application and
therefore i would like to
move for approval if i have a seconder
right thank you that's fine
so we've got this is wanting to prove it
and
councillor eves second it now does
anyone else want to
debate after this motion
for acceptance counselor
all right get your bike
um no i think um councillor mason has
summarized practically everything that i
would have said so um
i think it's a good improvement for the
community and
street scene is improved i can't see
there's any overwhelming harm
to the listed building so i am a little
bit lost as to why it's been refused
um so i would support that application
once everyone's debated we will take a
vote councillor gooding
thank you i haven't visited the site
last saturday um
i can see that it would only enhance the
area and i would endorse
exactly what council and mrs mason said
you know the benefits to the community
far way out outweigh any uh
any other issues thank you very much
right we've had a motion we've had a
second that we
will now take a vote before and can i
is it possible sorry just the officers
want to come back i do apologize
only just because we do have um some
suggested conditions that we would
suggest
being posed if we are going down the
line of approval i have a copy i can
show on the screen
if you think it necessary to view them
yes i think that would be necessary
please to be
transparent okay
i'm just gonna say can you read it and
there's nothing on the screen
so so we've got i don't know if you can
see it roughly
would you like members can you read that
or would you like them read out in full
put your glasses on everyone you see
okay
read out in full okay so the first one
is a time limit condition
condition so the development here by
permitted should be begun before the
expiration of three years from the date
of this permission
so that's the standard um one of
imposing all applications
the second one is materials so the
external facing materials to be used in
construction and development
here are permitted should be those
detailed within the application unless
alternative materials are proposed in
which case details should be submitted
to an agreed in writing by the local
planning authority prior to their use
and the third is compliance with
approved plans so development here by
permitting should be carried out in
complete accordance with the following
approved plans
as listed there and then the final is a
bat survey requirement so no work shall
commence until a bat survey has been
undertaken at the site
and submitted to an agreed in writing
with the local planning authority
any mitigation required shall be
undertaken in accordance with details to
be agreed in writing with the local
planning authority
and undertaken prior to works commencing
to construct the development hereby
approved
so just four conditions and then we've
got a standard reason for decision that
we put on there
which i can read out if you like but
it's a standard one
yes cancer stanley
[Music]
thank you chairman um with the
bat survey um do we know that there are
bats
in the locality or is is that just a
one condition that we always put in our
planning please don't look at me when
you ask that question please do the
offices because i don't sorry
no no no i do not know the answers uh
sorry i don't know the answer
it's going through the chair yes fine
it's not a standard condition that we
would impose it's normally something
that we ask for
ahead of or during the course of an
application um but and it's not the case
that any bats have necessarily been
present on the site it's
to ensure that a survey is undertaken to
make sure that protected species isn't
present and if it is
that any mitigation is undertaken prior
to any work starting on the site
does that answer your question did i
answer your question
not really oh sorry so um i mean
if you've got evidence that there are
bats no then have that then and have
that compliant
but if you have no evidence that there
are bats and never have been any bads
then the people that hold the premises
they would know if there was any bet so
we'd ask the question have you had any
bats they say no
there you go yes sorry in clarity
there's there's no evidence being
presented as part of this application
that suggests that bats are present but
natural england standing advice which is
what we have to look at when we consider
applications
tells us when certain scenarios are
likely to generate bats being present
and in those scenarios we either request
a bat survey
um during the course of an application
or in certain circumstances
like here we request it by condition so
it's not the case that bats have been
evident
evident on site that we've seen or
anything like that but it's natural
natural england standing advice that we
are required to look at
um as planning authority when we're
assisting applications
so we don't know what those requirements
are there there's
there is there are requirements that we
can view and it's it says things like um
if there's a game will ended in this
scenario a gable ended pre-1914 building
has the potential for bats to be present
and therefore as an authority we should
be requesting about survey
right thank you very much scenarios as
well thank you very much can you pass
the
microphone after wiping it down to uh
councillor mason please
that way could you wipe it down
thank you
very much thanks for mason
mrs mason thank you
cheer um i i'd just like to ask for some
clarification
on the officer on the reasons for
approval i know
i've moved approval but i can't read
what's on there i know they're pretty
standard i'd like to
include in that it may be included if
the officer can bear with me
that we do think we that the committee
feels it's an improvement
in our the committee's opinion on the
existing um
building and i would also like in the
reasons for approval the fact that
the um that any perceived harm
is more than outweighed by the public
benefit so
if the officer would mind i don't know
if it's included or not
and if my secondary is happy to for that
to be included
madame chairman i'd like that to be
included yes of course
thank you i'm getting nods from our
officers so that's fine right members
we've had a debate
quite healthily we've had um the motion
and it's been seconded
uh to vote for approval
of this application can i have a show of
hands can you please keep them up until
sonya tells me otherwise
thank you members below your hands that
is unanimous the application has been
approved thank you
that is the end of our business and i
will close the meeting
at 8 13. thank you very much
i told you it'd be